this video is sponsored by nebula okay
rolling
whoa
whoa lots of people follow this YouTube
channel because of the Vlogs I made
during my PhD in atmospheric physics at
the University of Exeter unfortunately
however I had to graduate at some point
and that necessarily meant the end of my
videos showing what doing a PhD was like
however there are lots of people out
there doing interesting PhD projects and
so in this video series I'm spending a
few days with a new researcher each
episode showing you what that life is
like learning a bit about them and
learning about the topic of their thesis
this time I'm out to the Department of
Aeronautics at Imperial College London
talking to Jesus who is experimenting
with an unusual rocket fuel
London and I am in my third year of my
PhD research so my PhD is titled
computational and experimental
characterization of water fuel holy fat
thrusters in simple terms what we are
trying to do is to develop a spacecraft
propulsion systems that instead of using
normal propellants like the ones that
are being flown in space right now they
are using water in a space propulsion
systems there are two main categories
you have chemical thrusters which are
the Rockets you see every day like NASA
and SpaceX with all these like massive
barn out of repellent and then you have
electric propulsion systems which is the
ones I'm developing myself so in
chemical Rockets you have a chemical
combustion and this is how you create
propellant in electrical systems what
you do is that you create a plasma and
then by sort of using electric or
magnetic fields then you accelerate the
plasma you get force from it the good
part about these systems which are like
conducted by plasma is that they are
very very efficient because a chemical
reaction let's say inefficiencies
because he can generate a lot of heat
it's also like energy being
uncontrollably released from the bones
of the propellant whereas you have
electric propulsion system what you have
is something that is like very very
fine-tuned that you could generate a
plasma and you just utilize most of it
to actually generate thrust but the
disadvantage is that the thrust you
produce from the systems is very very
small you have a coin in your hand and
the weight of the coin is more or less
the thrust that these systems are
producing in a space what happens is
that as you don't have any kind of
friction or whatsoever you are like
floating even if you have a small coin
pushing if you keep that one pushing for
like years you build up a massive
acceleration and this is because
something pushing for a very very long
time starts to accelerate the stuff more
and more and more and as there is
nothing to stop it at the end you get a
very very high speed this kind of
technology is already used on spacecraft
for example the recent Dart Mission used
an ion Thruster the most commonly used
fuel in these is the gas Xenon but
because it's massive inert not
radioactive and has a high ionization
potential meaning it's easy to rip an
electron off and generate a plasma but
other noble gases like Krypton are used
too unfortunately however producing
these gases is very energy intense and
expensive so Jesus is investigating
alternative fuels that are a bit easier
to come by for example the propellants
that we use nowadays are very toxic
environmentally not friendly and also
they are very very pricey so we want to
came up with a solution that solves all
these problems while it can also be
found in the vicinities of the entire
solar system when I arrived Jesus was
actually repairing a component of the
experiment that had developed a fault
over the weekend something that had to
be fixed before we could film that meant
that he asked me to climb into the
vacuum chamber to recalibrate a part of
the experiment now this may surprise
some of you but I don't actually own a
lab coat it's not like a requirement to
being a scientist but I have been given
for the shoot today and I'm allowed to
keep this for my very own live coat
just so what I want you to do here
you're going to see the laser and this
laser is in charge of measuring the
displacement of this first one whoa yeah
I feel like having like a kid's
playground
a very very expensive playground so this
whole slab moves slightly so when the
Thruster is firing you're going to see
uh this be pushed backwards and you're
going to measure that using this laser
that's down here so you bring it closer
it will start to turn green and that
means that the distance between the
plate and the laser is right so is green
too close the green is fine right is too
far away and orange is like sweet and
now it's green and it's gonna turn
orange just for
oh oh there you are yep we're flashing
orange nice well I honestly never
thought doing this job might be
recalibrating a component in a Plasma's
restaurant experiment here is a Thruster
let's say in very simple terms it's a
device that has an inlet in which the
propylene is being injected and then it
has a very specific magnetic field
topology so in this region that you see
here it is where the plasma is being
generated and it's been confined but all
this equipment that you see and then
it's being spelled out of it how do you
actually generate the plasma the whole
of a Thruster as itself it means nothing
it's useless we need to have something
called a cathode which is an electron
gun or a neutralizer this system is the
one that is emitting electrons and the
emission of electrons from this Castle
is the one that is going to excite the
plasma and this collision between the
electron and the neutral if it is very
energetic can generate an iron and then
there is a snowball effect in which in
case you have one ion then you start
generating two iron three ions and at
the end you have plasma being spelled
the good part about our kind of
equipment is that you only need to do
this
and then you have fuel for your
spacecraft what you can do is you can
have any kind of system that changes
from liquid water to water vapor and
then water vapor is being ionized and
this is how you Propel your spacecraft
with water vapor the other alternative
instead of using water vapor you can
have a water electrizer in front of your
spacecraft water electrolysis proportion
is very very useful because you separate
two propellants that serve two needs at
the same time oxium for the thruster
there are several kinds of ion thrusters
and as he already mentioned the Thruster
you just saw in the vacuum chamber the
subject of Jesus's PhD is a specific
kind that uses something called the hall
effect the whole effect is the movement
of charged particles when they are in a
perpendicular magnetic field it's a very
cool phenomena because you have two
things you have the electric field and
the electrons trying to go to one area
and then you have the magnetic field and
the electors are trying to hear it so
you mix on a straight line and a circle
what you have is a kind of ellipse so
it's like doing this kind of motion in
which on one hand it wants to get out
but on the other hand is being pushed to
the circular motion and all this stuff
is built up in this radius of the whole
of a Thruster so that we increase the
amount of time that the electrons are
inside of the channel because if the
electrons are there for a long time it's
going to be statistically more probable
that you are going to hit an electron
with a neutral and it's going to
generate an iron so by increasing the
amount of time the electron inside
within the channel you are increasing
the amount of probabilities of having an
electron anion and then therefore a
plasma over the course of the day we
filmed we fixed the component and sealed
the vacuum chamber and started pumping
it down to very low pressure after all
this is equipment designed to operate in
space it would be impossible to get the
plasma engine to work at atmospheric
pressure that pumping down gave me a
chance to ask Jesus about his background
and the unusual way his PhD was financed
I studied in Spain in Madrid for my
aerospace engineer background and then I
moved to the Netherlands to tildel and I
started there my Master's Degree and
then I moved to Switzerland at the CERN
the particle accelerator enthusias there
of work experience and when I was
working there I was also working at the
Swiss Space Center which is like the
entity in Switzerland that manages all
this space stuff what happened was that
I was in Switzerland with a very like
generous payslip I said I want to do a
PSD like 100 right so he talked with my
supervisor I didn't have any funding and
he accepted me as a PS these students
being self-funded at the start I didn't
have any funding as I said so I was like
here on my own and I took this chance
because I love science and I wanted to
do something that really like fills my
heart and after one and a half years of
like working here being self-funded I
got funding for my PSD so the European
Space Agency found my project
interesting and now I'm getting paid by
them to conduct this experimentation the
my tribal Space Program
oh yeah that's a very good game played a
little bit and it's quite realistic like
the stuff you can generate there apart
from like dark matter and other kind of
energy that are not yet there yet I
think it's a very realistic follower now
when Jesus emailed me about his project
he mentioned that we could generate some
plasma and get the engine working for
the camera great but there was another
facility at Imperial that he mentioned
that got me really excited to visit so
why do you have a flight simulator first
of all for the students or the first and
second year to actually like experience
what are actually the physics of motion
of an aircraft and also the busy
students and professors that give like
do research on it the good part is that
you can model your own aircraft and you
can see how you actually will perform in
reality so as a student you can design
an aircraft you can put that into the
system and then you can control that
aircraft and see how it handles
in a six-axis flight simulator I have a
big project in first year it's got
aerial vehicle design and there's also
one lab in second year I think you have
to design a control system
this is so cool does this have anything
to do with plasma thrusters no but how
many times do you get an opportunity to
fly one of these
we're about to fly well I think it's a
fighter jet
Um this can only go well
locking the doors
hello okay that's all all right whenever
you're ready Simon press the start
button ready ready Full Throttle
all right
whoa uh current speed back one
oh okay
so which direction we are heading west
is that correct let me that will take
you a heading east
right okay down we go we are buzzing
Central London at 400 feet oh god
oh good grief
recommend decreasing the speed
that's a tree that's a building
we are bouncing around Southeastern
England I think we may have crashed oh I
feel a little bit motion sick I won't
lie I I do yeah actually
oh thank you yeah that was amazing
someone's glad that we're on Solid
Ground
so what we're going to do now is that
we're gonna try to ignite the Thruster
using oxygen an oxygen when we turn a
plasma on it's going to be in a mix
between green and yellow and this is
because every plasma brights as a
certain time wavelength that our eyes
interpret as a different color we are
going to generate electric field between
the Thruster and the cathode that's the
first step and the second one is that we
are going to put propellant through the
Thruster so the combination of the
electric field plus the propellant is
going to create this plasma that we are
going to see and the third step is to
start the magnetic field and when we
start the magnetic field we are going to
have a whole effect electric field
magnetic field and a plasma in between
them and then what kind of force you're
expecting to generate today probably 30
million something like that I think the
building will be all right laughs
okay whenever you are ready ready
[Music]
over the course of the afternoon we
fired up the plasma Thruster dozens of
times testing putting different
quantities of oxygen through the
Thruster depending on the concentration
of oxygen plasma it would appear
anything from green to Yellow a bit like
how the note of a car engine changes
depending on the fuel mix you use and
generates slightly different amounts of
thrust but needless to say it all looked
awesome so in the future what we want to
do is to put this stuff but into space
right now we are making sure that the
efficiency levels and the technology is
competitive and once we have all this
research done what we want to do is to
fly it in our actual spacecraft in orbit
proof of concept and then yeah
commercialize it if I will have to
choose a specimation for this probably I
will choose to go to one of the moons of
Jupiter you go there you need something
that is very very efficient so you
cannot use like a standard rocketry and
if you use whole effect thrusters you
can use this propellant for
interplanetary Missions or or for
example going to Jupiter and explore one
of the moons of Jupiter and possibly
gather water from this planet in order
for example to come back to earth my
idea after my PhD is currently unknown I
would like to like keep working in the
space field is possible like work for
any space agency I think that would be
great otherwise I might spread the word
of science as you do and join your your
stuff which is also very good do you
think you'll see this technology be used
in the next couple of decades yeah for
sure like I think the timing scale has
probably been optimistic 10 years being
pessimistic maybe takes 20. it may be a
decade or two from being used on a
mission but what you've seen today may
not be the last time you see a
water-fueled spacecraft Thruster the
next time might just be around one of
Jupiter's moons putting these videos
together is tough because every one of
the PhD students I featured in this
series have had such interesting stories
to tell and you can only cover so much
in the video for example this isn't
Jesus's only research project previously
he worked on transformable spacecraft
and was even invited to fly a prototype
of one on a microgravity flight by the
European Space Agency he talks about
this as well as giving advice to
prospective PhD students in an extra
video I've uploaded to my nebula page
most episodes of the series actually
have such bonus content on nebula which
is the streaming service I am lucky
enough to run with a team of creative
friends over 600 000 people have signed
up to nebula and it's not hard to see
why there are over a hundred educational
creators uploading their videos to
nebula so it's got tons of exclusive
content like my extended videos but also
nebula Originals such as Abby Thorns the
prince extremities and great cities so
it's like the section of YouTube you
already watch but with bonus content and
with no adverts whatsoever nebula
instead operates on a subscription model
with your subscription fee divided
between the creators you watch so by
signing up and watching videos from me
you directly support this series and
further videos from me if you sign up
with my link in the description you get
an amazing 40 discount on a yearly
subscription meaning you can support my
videos stop seeing adverts on videos
from your favorite creators and be
introduced to new series and new faces
for just 2.50 a month and for that 2.50
a month you also get free access to
nebula classes where nebula creators
show you behind the curtain and how they
make videos in in-depth lessons it may
well be the best money you spend this
year and while I would certainly
appreciate it if you went to
go.nebula.tv Simon Clark I think you are
going to appreciate it too
thank you for watching the video and
thank you of course to Jesus for being
so generous with his time and letting me
on that flight simulator if you enjoyed
the video please do pop it a like and
share it with your friends who you think
may be interested but also do check out
previous episodes of this series linked
on the screen and in the description
that just leads me to say thank you
again for watching and I'll see you in
the next one